The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So I will go into a
little about what the class
is, and what you're
going to do.
I'll just put one slide about
requirements and outcomes.
So what are the requirements?
We require you to be a good
programmer with a lot of
programming experience.
As I said, we are going down
to very bare metal.
And there won't be any
niceties of just
writing Java code.
So you're going to run into a
lot of these kind of issues.
Fluent in C is --
I wouldn't call it a 100%
requirement, but it really
helps if you're fluent in C.
If not, you'll have to
probably spend a lot of time
trying to understand C, C++.
And in this class that means --
just start doing it today,
just get a C book and then
try to understand.
If you run a lot of Java it
might be an easy transition.
But get to the transition
fast, don't wait.
What are we expecting
at the end?
We expect at the end
for you to know --
AUDIENCE: I have to go.
Thank you very much
[INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: So what
do we expect?
We expect at the end you'll
probably understand a lot of
fundamentals and concepts of
parallel programming --
both hardware and software.
Because the nice
thing about --
or the nice thing or the
bad thing about Cell --
is a lot of hardware conceptuals
to expose.
There's no nice abstraction
layers in there.
You'll understand a lot of
issues about parallel
performance.
We started here, you write a
program, compile -- it's not
just order n you're
looking for.
You're looking for all
these constants.
All these things matter,
basically.
You should be able to synthesize
a fairly complex
parallel program by the end,
because that's what your group
project's going to be.
And you'll get a lot of hands-on
experience with the
Cell processor, so we'll
understand this one
instance very well.
So that is what we are expecting
will happen at the
end of this 3.5 weeks.
So the project.
You proposed the projects, we
did something different.
So it's all your ideas that
we are going to do.
We selected seven groups out
of these -- there are seven
projects in there --
mainly based on the strength
of the project proposals.
And I was pretty impressed with
the height of things you
guys proposed.
So here are the seven
projects.
Let's actually try to figure
out who's who.
Who's doing distributed
real-time ray tracer?
OK, that's not true.
OK, how about the global
illumination?
OK.
Linear algebra pack?
OK, good.
Molecular dynamics?
OK.
Speech synthesizer?
Soft radio?
OK.
Backgammon tutor?
And there are some people who
are, I think, in this class
thinking that they
can join a group.
So at the end, there are a few
groups that only have one
member, so probably go ahead
and talk to them and see
whether they are willing
to work with people.
So I'll give you a little bit of
time, because I'm going to
finish early.
OK, let's ask -- who are
the people who are
hoping to join a group?
Is there anybody who came?
I got a few emails, I don't
know that anybody's here.
Oh good.
So it's not going
to be a problem.
So I did the project
characteristics.
You can see that they are
ambitious projects, but
accomplishable.
I was worried that people would
say, "I'm going to build
this entire thing", and it's
going to take a year.
But I think most of the projects
that they proposed
are doable.
Another thing is important
and relevant things.
I think for a lot of these
things, if the code is done
right other people might
even use it.
I think this can start
something, it's not just going
to be this project.
And there's a lot of opportunity
to sizzle.
I think some people will come
up with these things that I
think at the end will
be so amazing.
And that's what got
me excited.
But get them started as soon as
possible, because this is
not a semester course, this is
going to run so fast. There's
only a few all nighters
you can pull,
basically is what it is.
So there's a note of caution.
Cell processor is very new.
We heard about that today.
I mean this is a really
cool thing, but it has
its problems in there.
It's not an easy architecture
to work with.
There is though this
nice abstraction.
So it's just then from this
being completely abstracted
out, writing Java code, to
all the way to metal.
So it's just almost a jump
from going to a higher
language of assembly.
So there's a huge, big gap in
there, and that's going to be
a lot of issues in there.
The tool chain is very
thin and brittle.
So my pointing out all those
things, you wish there's a
tool, but there's nothing.
And even the existing tools --
we just got the SDK 2.0 into
working I think this morning
-- and so there might
be issues in there.
Most of the staff have
limited experience.
For example, SDK 2.0.
We just got it working, so we
haven't used it yet in there.
So that can create problems,
especially in
a fast moving course.
The projects you are doing
are of your own making.
Most of the classes --
if you need to [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
classes, we actually come up
with the projects, TAs go and
implement it once, we know
all the gotchas.
And then when you get the
project we know there's an
existence proof that
it's doable, it
works, the tools work.
We know at least there's
one path through it.
There's nothing like
that here.
Everybody's kind of just jumping
at it head on, and
hoping that we can read them.
And we might find issues that
are very hard, and that's why
we actually have very
close contact with
those guys at IBM.
So if things happen, we'll call
them and they will be
available to help us.
But it's not something you can
say -- oh yeah, I know, just
go do that.
Or -- here's the way out.
So there might be issues like
that, so we have to be very
careful of that.
And you will face these kinds of
problems. That's more given
than anything else, so
be ready for that.
This is not just writing some
high level code and getting
away with it.
And you're all in
this together.
So the staff, you,
me, everybody --
we're just doing it for the
first time in some sense.
And that's the fun part about
it, because as you pointed
out, there might be some stuff
that you guys come out with
that will become more like
folklore and the basis for the
things people do.
Because you might say --
hey, there's a neat
way of doing that.
You will be the first to
do this kind of thing.
So there's that time, but on
planning the three week course
it's a large chunk to bite.
If it is more for a PhD,
then you can say --
OK, spend three months
figuring it out.
There's no other time limit.
So we will try to manage this
process, but you need to try
to -- expectations of what you
are trying to get done, and
then be able to get it done.
So you have to always
balance this out.
If you're running into issues,
get to us very fast. Because
we need to figure it out.
And we might have to actually
also figure it out from
somebody else, so we can
escalate it up and get the
information.
Because three weeks are
going to go so fast.
How many people are taking
the class for a grade?
So people who are taking it for
a grade, here is what we
are going to do.
The first thing, what I call
mini quizzes, is just a prop
so you will come into class.
So the way I am going to do that
is, at the beginning of
the class I am going to give you
a piece of paper with two
questions from the
previous lecture.
You can do anything you
want to answer it.
You can talk to people,
look it up, whatever.
And then at the end
of the class
basically we want it back.
And the only requirement is, you
have to come individually
to pick your thing up, and you
have to come individually to
hand it in, and you can't write
somebody else's anwers
physically, but you can
talk to each other.
So we'll try to make it a little
bit entertaining, and a
little bit thought-provoking,
but nothing like you have to
spend hours doing it.
It'll be probably
five minutes.
Normally we will do a break
inbetween, so you probably can
talk to each other and come up
with some of the answers.
So this is just the fact that
the people who are actually
getting the grades will be
coming to class, more than
anything else I'll be testing.
And then we have these lab
projects at the beginning,
that will get some grade.
And the final group project.
And then we have a final
competition.
So since everybody's not doing
the same project, we are going
to decide on performance --
so how well your code ran, how
much MIPS or [? GOPs ?] you
were able to get from that.
And how raw performance
is in there.
And then we will also
look at it from a
complexity point of view.
So for example, as I pointed
out, if you do matrix
multiplier you get certain
performance, so if you do
[? FF3, ?] you get certain
performance.
So just absolute numbers is not
what matters, but how far
you can get hard
algorithm too.
Completeness.
So were you able to get
your project through?
How much do you actually have a
compete solution at the end
that something works?
That's important.
Algorithmic complexity -- how
much of a complexity did you
bite in, both from more of a
pure algorithm point of view,
and also implementing some
shared complexity in there.
And demo and presentation.
So OK, those two.
So we are going to select
a winning team.
We haven't figured exactly what,
but we'll give everybody
a gift set depending on --
this is what we are aiming
at right now.
Also we are going to invite the
winning team to spend a
day at IBM TJ Watson.
You get to give a presentation
to a bunch of people there,
and probably go see what
they are doing.
That should be a fun
day to spend.
We haven't scheduled a day,
depending on the class
schedule and stuff like that,
the winning team will go spend
a day out in there.
That will be a fun thing to
do, there's a lot of cool
stuff going on there.
They will get to actually
interact with some
researchers, see what they
do, as well as present
this work to them.
And since this is new
everybody's excited.
I think hopefully we'll come
up with a team that will do
things that other people will be
interested in and will use.
So these kind of come from
backward because I wanted to
get Mike Perrone first.
So my name is Saman --
Saman Amarasinghe --
I live in CSAIL.
I have had a lot of
interest in --
[LAUGHTER]
Not as much as you
guys probably.
I have a lot of interest in
languages, compilers, and
computer architecture.
So if you have been at this game
for a long time, in the
early 1990s there was a huge
surge in parallel performance,
work on parallelism, and at
that time I did the SUIF
parallelizing compiler
in there.
And then, everybody says -- hey,
there's this Moore slope
of performance, who cares
about parallelism?
So there was this decade
when this paralellism
kind of died down.
I kind of hid under the radar
and kind of survived through
that thing, and then again I
think parallelism coming up.
So we are doing a bunch of
parallel work in here.
So I probably have a perspective
that goes
somewhere old, and
then coming up.
Probably Aaron can also
relate to that.
Aaron: There's one of
us who did that.
PROFESSOR: Yeah exactly.
Going through that, kind
of survived in that.
And Rodric is sitting there.
So Rodric is right now at IBM
PJ Watson, but he's probably
going to live at CSAIL next
month, so he's going to be
here more than me in fact.
He was actually in the lab until
a few months ago, as a
research scientist. He's also
interested in a lot of these
kinds of things -- compilers,
architecture, parallel
architecture, and
FPGA type work.
And then we have two TAs.
Where's David and Phil?
OK, get up.
So they actually have
some experience.
Probably they are about a week
ahead of you on understanding
Cell, not too much.
They are going to lead the
recitations and be available
to help you in there.
So really use those resources
as much as possible.
And then we are going to have
a huge amount of guest
lecturers, and I was pretty
happy with the
kind of list we got.
Mike Perrone just came and gave
you the lecture, and Alan
is going to talk
in a few weeks.
And Professor Arvind, Brad
Kuszmaul, Mike Acton -- that
Mike Perrone talk about is
going to come at the end.
And Bill Thies, who was one
of the PhD students in the
Streamit group, is going
to talk about
the Streamit language.
So the way we have kind of
structured the class is, how
do you go about extracting
parallelism.
There's implicit parallelism.
And sometimes the
current way of
everything done by hardware.
In the next lecture, I will just
touch upon superscalar
hardware, what it is and
what its problems are.
Implicit parallelism means
you can do by compiler.
So you write a C program, and
let the compiler deal with the
parallelism.
For as long as you are a
programmer, you don't have to
deal with that thing.
In lectures 11 and 12
I will talk about
parallelizing compilers.
So we'll cover how you can
do that [? in C. ?]
So that means kind of abstract
it out, and leaving it out of
the end programmer.
So the hardware exposes it, but
we put a software layer.
And then the other end is
explicit parallelism.
That's where, I think, we are
going to spend most of the
time in this class.
So in the first part of explicit
parallelism is the
library approach.
What that means is you are using
MPI type things, so you
are basically at the metal
dealing with this parallelism.
I am going to do lecture
4 on concurrency.
How many people took 6.170 last
year when I was teaching?
OK.
I did a lecture on concurrency
there, so something very
similar I'm going to do in here
-- to get the basics of
parallelism.
In order to write a parallel
program, the program has to
run concurrently.
There's a lot of issues for
writing concurrent programs.
It is necessary to get parallel,
it's not sufficient.
There are a lot more other
things to worry about.
But let's deal with those
kind of issues --
deal with things like
synchronization, deadlocks,
and issues like that.
So I'm going to give that, and
then Rodric is going to have a
few lecture on design
patterns.
So if you want to write a
parallel program, how do you
look at it?
Different algorithms will
have different ways of
parallelizing.
So he's going to go about
looking at these kind of
parallel patterns.
If you have this kind of
program, here is a
way to look at it.
Here's another way
to look at it.
So kind of go through
that in there.
And in concurrency we work
with a lot more abstract
parallel model, and get slowly
down to all the realism needed
in dealing with Cell.
And then we are going to have
a bunch of guest lectures,
mainly dealing with other ways
of doing parallelism.
So this is one way.
We are going to have a lecture
on Streamit, because you might
be able to use that also
as a way on Cell.
So a little bit of high
abstraction, we are trying to
make that available on Cell.
So if that comes to, then you
might be able to even have
that as a part of your
toolbox in there.
The other three talks are
about very different
approaches for parallelism.
I think they will give you a
big picture view, it's not
that you're just going
through one
parallelling down in there.
I think at the end of to the day
you'll understand not only
how to deal with Cell, but
kind of a general way of
looking at parallelism, and
maybe from that approach
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] parallelism
in there.
So the lectures are organized
as follows.
We are now at the end
of the day here.
Tomorrow we'll have
a recitation on
getting to know Cell.
We are trying to figure out a
good room, so just check your
email to figure out exactly
where we are going to have it,
because we are trying
to figure it out.
We want to find a room with
machines so everybody can
actualy get hands-on experience
in kind of a
lecture format.
And then we will have the
architecture, just general
parallel architecture, and an
introduction to concurrent
programming.
And then Rodric is going to
have individual meets with
individual groups,
trying to get the
groups' projects going.
So at that point kind of figure
out how we are doing
it, have some early ideas about
it so you can start
thinking and start the process
of doing that.
You can start working on Cell
probably from tomorrow, but
really get a day to kind of
get familiarized, and then
here start the project.
And then we will have
some lectures on
design patterns in here.
And as we go we'll have more
hands-on experience also.
Then we'll have a lecture
on Streamit.
So if you are using Streamit for
a part of the run program,
you'll be able to understand
what's going on.
And we'll get to some debugging
tools, hopefully we
will have to deal with these
things before that, but here's
something that if you're really
stuck, to get a breadth
of tools available in here.
And then we'll talk in general
about debugging and
performance monitoring and
performance optimization.
So at this point hopefully you
have done the first cart, you
have figured out what problems,
and start optimizing
things in here.
And then we'll going into a
little bit more breadth,
things like traffic paralleizing
compilers that I
talk about, getting implicit
parallelism in here.
And then we will have a bunch of
guest lecturers coming in.
And we'll talk about some
hardware and the future,
because we are just starting
this very new phase in
programming that might change
almost everybody.
Five years, ten years down the
line if you go through
computer science, you might have
a very different flavor,
if what people think of
parallelism takes hold.
So let's look at some future,
and talk about that.
And it's a nice way to
finish the lectures.
A few more days and then
we'll have group
presentations in here.
So each group will get about
15 minutes time to present
what they have done and give
a little bit of a demo.
And then finally on
Friday we will
have awards and reception.
So this is what we got.
Any questions?
AUDIENCE: For recitations, if
we're not in a room with
machines should we
bring laptops?
PROFESSOR: So that's
a good question.
Who doesn't have a laptop
they can bring?
OK.
If that is the case, we can have
it in any room we want,
and have the network.
And we might have one or two
additional machines for people
who don't have a laptop.
And that actually will work
much better than everybody
marching into some kind of a
computer room that's not
structured properly
for doing a class.
OK, that actually helps a lot.
That's a good point, I think
that helps a lot.
OK, we'll do that
that way then.
AUDIENCE: How do we get access
to these machines?
PROFESSOR: OK.
Rodric, you --
RODRIC RABBAH: Every room has
a PS3 dedicated to them.
And every group has accounts
on their dedicated PS3.
I have your usernames
and passwords.
I will pass them out tomorrow,
because I'm going to propagate
the new SDK to all the PS3's --
to sort of test it with one
and make sure everything's
working.
So you'll get them at the first
recitation tomorrow.
Unless you really want them
today, then come talk to me or
send me email.
PROFESSOR: You'll get
to take home --
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yes.
RODRIC RABBAH: Yes.
PROFESSOR: We couldn't even put
it in the machine room,
because they were scared
somebody was going
to take them home.
So we actually have it in a
different room -- closed,
nicely locked --
or on the network.
So I have been a very popular
person lately, a lot of people
have tried to bribe me
to get access to
one of these masters.
AUDIENCE: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
AUDIENCE: How much does
the PS3 cost?
PROFESSOR: Officially $600, but
then eBay's going up to
like $2,500 these days.
AUDIENCE: No.
PROFESSOR: That's gone down?
AUDIENCE: They're down between
$400 and $500.
PROFESSOR: Oh, OK.
AUDIENCE: They tried
[? to rope me in. ?]
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: OK.
But during Christmas
it was down for --
a few desperate payers who
were trying to bribe me.
[LAUGHTER]
So I guess their volume
has caught up to --
AUDIENCE: No, the demand
has dropped.
PROFESSOR: OK.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: Will we get to
see the Playstation?
PROFESSOR: Tomorrow we
can bring one --
AUDIENCE: I can bring
one [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: If you put
a game in it's fun.
You can put a game in and play
it, but this is going to be
Linux so it's a little
bit boring.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: So these are
things that actually
cannot play the games.
PROFESSOR: It can.
Interestingly, mostly these
game machines are sold for
less than production value.
So Microsoft, Nintendo, and
Sony before made sure that
nobody can run anything other
than the published games that
they've charged $25 per pop to
recover the cost. Huh?
No, $60 for the game.
I think they are charging $25
from the game maker just for
the privilege of running
the game.
That's how they make
their money.
But, [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
when they made PS3 bootable
by Linux.
So in fact, it's much cheaper,
you get a Blu-Ray player, and
this Cell processor for a lot
less than the production cost.
AUDIENCE: Does Linux on
the PS3 run on top
of the PS3 OS though?
PROFESSOR: No.
It just boots up PS3.
What it does is in fact --
right now, you don't get
access to the graphics
processor properly.
So you can run open G11.
You have framebuffer access,
but you don't get the full
graphics access out of that.
AUDIENCE: Which distribution
are we using?
PROFESSOR: Which one?
AUDIENCE: We're using
Yellow Dog.
AUDIENCE: So in other words,
Mario and Luigi are
subsidizing what we're
going to do.
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: Yeah, exactly.
All those shoot them up games
are basically what subsidizes.
Actually he said, in one sense,
you get the processor
down to $200 because they are
selling all the other things.
And the other thing, actually
if you want to build a high
performance Cell farm, it's
probably cheaper because I
think that the Cell blend
would be $2,000.
It should be cheaper to
buy a bunch of PS3's,
connect them together.
But there might be issues about
things like network
access, file access, because as
you pointed out, the board
access is pretty primitive.
Because for games you don't
need this high bandwidth
connection, you just need
to download it once.
So there might be issues
using it for cluster.
OK.
Anything else?
OK, good.